cette heure l'ouverture de la
boulangerie d'angélique situe à montigny
le bretonneux
le personnel est dans les starting
blocks pour accueillir les clients ça se
prépare des semaines à l'avancé au
niveau de l'organisation et puis
la fabrication sur la dernière semaine
et puis on commence tôt
là trois heures ce matin peu de monde à
l'ouverture là que démarre vers 9h30 à
ce moment là les clients sont au rendez
vous prêt à retirer leurs commandes j'ai
acheté un pas de surprise du pain pour
le foie gras enfin toujours de ma
boulangerie préféré puisque je suis une
bonne cliente j'ai commandé deux bûches
une bûche aux mousses trois chocolats et
une bûche mousse fruits ainsi que trois
tradi pour accompagner le repas de
réveillon au niveau de l'organisation de
salariés sont destinés au retrait des
commandes et deux autres employés
réalisent les ventes directes autre que
la traditionnelle bûche de noël sur les
tables crevettes bulots huîtres ou
encore langouste sont les stars du
réveillon à la poissonnerie le chemin
des pêcheurs de voisins-le-bretonneux
c'est le rush depuis le début de la
semaine et à une partie qui vient
récupérer leur commande tout ce qu'on
peut savoir comment auparavant donc il
ya les pâtisseries mer et les petites
choses emporté et sinon ceux qui
viennent à demain minutes et puis qui
prennent les choses sur place avec la
crise sanitaire noël est l'occasion pour
les clients de dépenser sans compter on
exigeants sur la qualité en fait voilà
c'est vrai se font plaisir comme on est
en petit comité
passer un bon moment et oublié un peu
tout cet environnement toxique comme on
n'a pas fait des restos cette année on
n'a pas vu les gens donc on a fait
attention toute l'année pour moi c'est
l'occasion plaisir et il reste une
dernière que a affronté pour passer un
bon réveillon